what's that believe nation we put out a
lot of content and I often get asked can
you summarize it down to some of your
favorite clips and so that's what this
video today is all about some of my most
favorite rules from the top 10 series
February 2017 edition I hope you enjoy
and as always guys as they're watching
if you hear something that really
resonates with you leave it down the
comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well and when you write
it down it's much more likely to sink in
for yourself as well enjoy you are
unusually fearless and willing to go in
the face of other people telling you
something that's crazy and I know a lot
of pretty crazy people you still stand
out where does that come from or how do
you think about making a decision when
everyone tells you this is a crazy idea
where do you get the internal strength
to do that
well office well I'd say I actually
think I feel feel fair quite strongly so
it's not as though I just have the
absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly but there are times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do you do
it in spite of the fear so speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think III I should if you should think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it it's normal
to be to feel fear like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fair so you just feel it
and let the importance of it drive you
to do it anyway yeah you know actually
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so I'm starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding or
really love if if we could celebrate
every breath that we take because
nothing is a guarantee if we could
celebrate the breath and the exhale
which is being alive without you know my
car won't start
all geez you know the cat drop dead hey
you know I think I need a lobotomy you
know uh I mean there are things that are
very very important in life that we we
just we don't think about you know and
then one of the most worrisome things
that I went through for years is you
freaked a freaked out about your past
you're worried you're scared to death of
the future that's all you're thinking
about but then now doesn't exist you
know and I think that's a grave mistake
that we like I've always had this really
gross dangerous mentality of the no
consideration of failure just never even
considering the thought of failing like
if I want something I just go until I
get it and that doesn't always work but
I believe that the depth of anybody
struggle will determine the height of
their success and I believe that
everything that I've gone through in my
whole life you know
people ask me what would you change I
wouldn't change a thing because
everything that I've gone through is
made me who I am today
so I'm sitting here very strong a very
complicated you know and it got a lot of
love for a lot a lot of people Jesus
struggled and went through things you
know everybody went through the old
thing and uh and people who slandered
him I mean I feel like if Jesus can go
what he went through
Who am I I'm nobody
there's a guy from the little bandits
that just do this music you know but I
was just such a real person I don't
consider myself a celebrity at all I was
just so real and I love people that you
know man I just flow through this thing
you know and I let my music got like I
got me where you got to be to go but God
ain't gonna just guide you straight to
success not God he gonna guide you
through a lot of mess first so that when
you get the success you know how to
appreciate it you know how to stay with
it and know how to take care of it not
that and that's called longevity
I'm very spiritual person and I follow
my spirit and I do what my spirit tells
me to do you know and I don't have a set
like oh I want to play this type of
character and I won't play that type of
character I'm receptive to anything you
know and when the right thing comes
along if it's serious that was funny if
it's silly if it's low but see I'm but
it put it this way I do I just do
whatever makes me I get the most
gratification from as an artist you know
I do music albums and nobody buys my
records I do them because I love making
music you know and that's the same way
I'm about movies I don't make movies
because I'm going to thinking let me do
this because then people are come or how
much will the movie make and I'm trying
to make the audience do that I do what a
feels right for me
they're about following a dream I would
say if you truly believe in something
and you really have a passion for
something then go for it I think there's
a lot of obstacles that you have to go
through and he started in the crib I was
a baby and from the craver all the way
to age 11 more or less I have what is
called lucid dreaming which means that
you dream that you are awake so I
literally saw monsters I was used to
monsters I loved them but you know at
the very early age I made a deal with
them to allow me to go to the bathroom
because I was so afraid that I ended up
paying my crib you know we stayed
friends
you know there are only two things you
can do in art or in narrative and
storytelling you can tell about the good
stuff in life which has always been very
boring to me and you can tell stories
about the dark side of life which has
been much more attractive to me why not
when I talked to three first-time
filmmakers or first-time filmmakers I
always tell them look making movies is
eating a sandwich and the only thing
that gets a little better is as the
years go by you get a little more bread
but it's always there but isn't it that
true of life also I think it is I mean I
use another metaphor for life but for
film I tell you that one fits and but in
the end somehow you find the joy well
you and you end up convincing yourself
that it's peanut butter
Ang's ever is it ever peanut bug I want
to believe it is you look back and go oh
yes I did that I tell you without a
doubt we we may say this with is the
greatest being an artist in whatever
discipline dance painting theater
whatever you want is the greatest work
on earth I mean is truly this heartening
in a in this way or that way but so is
every job so is every job I when I was
younger I worked with my father on real
estate for about five years I was the
worst car salesman in the history of
Carl sighs McCullough salesmanship I was
Fisher too honest
yeah people would come and say what
about designing you know Glengarry Glen
Ross I would not get the knife set I
would I would be I would surely live in
I should be out out it was terrible my
father said you you're you're terrible
but I wonder the other vendors whenever
whenever I went out the other salesmen
whenever I went out to a client they
actually laughed behind my back actually
physically were laughing behind my back
and I was the worst but unreal said I
was good I was good or lucid and my
father used to say you have to do this
to show that you can have an honest
living do an honest living and what I
did is work on real estate in the
mornings and I did monsters in the
afternoon but I know that when you have
a real job
I painted highways one summer in which
the cancers I mean a real job has equal
heartbreaking something that in politics
well I mean this is for I think it's one
of the things that people really
misunderstand as his glorious it is to
be able to do the things you're
passionate about and to be an artist
it's still a job it is not diligent work
yeah yeah it is it is but but God God
bless anyone that can do this is
beautiful and you have to truly be
grateful and the only way to remain
objective about how grateful you need to
be is present your
present to your past self when you're
twenty years old and if you go and talk
to yourself at 20 years old and said
would you like to be doing this movie
with this button what do you think your
response at age training would be
absolutely yes you know some jobs you
learn by going to college and they give
you an education then you bring that to
work and some jobs you learn by just
being on the job and from curst part 3
on all the way up to Jurassic world my
knowledge of how to be on a set how to
act and how to handle myself on set and
approach work is continuing to grow I've
learned a lot on every job it would be
smart went on a job to be a sponge pick
somebody and learn from it I'm getting
to the point now where I have more
experience than a lot of the people that
are on the set and I'm actually at a
point where I can teach other people so
that's pretty cool dude
I enjoy doing them but more than that
actually let me rephrase it I think the
reason why I enjoy it so much is because
how much the people get off the audience
appreciates what we do you know there's
a lot of things I could be doing outside
of the industry even within the industry
but you know I don't know what the
satisfaction would be the same you know
because to be a part of something that
people really appreciate as much as
maybe certain people hate to admit it
and it's important to us you know as
humans it's like you want to believe
that you know what you're putting out
there and what you've dedicated so much
time to is it there's a certain degree
of acknowledgment and more than
acknowledgement and appreciation you
know obviously this one's been
appreciated for a long time and it's it
that's a great thing if it's in your
heart you have to push forward if it's
in your heart because I'm from Kansas
City Missouri who would ever thought
that you can build an empire but if you
put your mind to it and push for to push
for a key no matter if your family tell
you it's a hobby you need to do
something else to get money or whatever
man is like if you believe in and you
got to follow that dream you
man because if I didn't that wouldn't be
in any strange music to come to any
interview in because I followed my dream
after everybody knocked me down you have
to push forward if you believe in it you
will it's even it Scott keep pushing I
look I look towards the future and the
future is just you know it's more to do
is more more steps to climb and stuff so
I don't really look at you know what I'm
doing right now I just so every time I
do something I move on and see how could
I get better and I'm never satisfied you
know I think I always know I could do
better you know always knew you could do
it better I can do better yeah I know
there are so many kids out there that
feel the way that I did when I was a kid
just awkward and not excelling at one
thing in particular and not cool and um
skateboarding was my way out of that and
I hope that if not with skateboarding
they find in something else they do but
I hope that they're not afraid to try
something different because you can't
listen to the haters that's my best
advice to anyone if I had listened to
the haters I would have quit a long time
ago I would have quit I was 11 years old
like I used to get bashed by
professional skaters because my style
was was dorky or it was all circus it
was you know but you can't you've gotta
believe in yourself a lot of people kind
of mean they say well I want to be an
entrepreneur and I go that's great
what's your idea and they go well I
don't have one yet
and I say well I think you should go get
a job as a busboy or something till you
find something you're really passionate
about because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance it is so hard you pour so
much your life into this thing there are
such rough moments in time that most
people give up I don't blame them it's
really tough and it consumes your life I
mean if you're if you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's it's been done
but it's rough I mean because it's a
pretty much you know a 18 hour a day job
seven days a week for a while so
unless you have a lot of passion about
this you're gonna not survive you're
gonna give it up so you've got to have
an idea or a problem or a wrong that you
want to write that you're passionate
about otherwise you're not going to have
the perseverance to stick it through and
I think that's half the battle right
there it's hard to remember how bad it
was you know in 1980s with IBM taking
over the world with the PC with Doss out
there it was it was far worse than the
Apple - they tried to copy the Apple -
and they done a pretty bad job and you
needed to know a lot and so things were
kind of slipping backwards and Macintosh
was you saw the 1984 commercial you put
that I hope you have that in your
archives
you know Macintosh was basically this
this relatively small company you know
in Cupertino California taking on the
Goliath IBM and saying wait a minute
your way is wrong this is not the way we
want computers to go this is not the
legacy we want to leave this is not what
we want our kids to be learning this is
wrong and we are going to show you the
right way to do it and here it is it's
called Macintosh and this is so much
better that it's gonna beat you and we
are gonna do it and that's what Apple
stood for thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what did you
think
what rules stood out the most for you
what are you going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business leave
it down in the comments below and I'm
gonna join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to sue me
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and sharing
that picture of how your one word is
peace and what it means to you I really
appreciate the support and I'm glad that
the book had an impact on your life so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love have an amazing day I'll see you
soon